So, let's take a look at problem one.
That is, what's the probability of
getting the observation sequence,
given lambda, given an HMM.
It's the first I want to look at
a naive solution, and then, you'll see
how the cool solution is so much
much better than the naive solution.
So, let's start off by pretending,
assume for the moment,
we actually know the sequence of states.
Okay?
So, that's q sub 1 through q sub cap t.
Right, q sub 1 through q sub cap t.
That's the actual state
at time one through time,
to each one of them is an s sub j,
right?
So, maybe it goes from state three,
to two, to four or whatever.
One through t is the time, okay?
So, we're going to assume that.
And the other thing we're going to
assume is that the observations
only depend upon
the state that you're in.
So, when we say, independent
observations, what we mean is
that if you knew this state, then
the probability of observation is just
dependent on the state and
not dependent upon anything else.
Well, if that's the case,
then the probability of the particular
observation, observation sequence,
given the state sequence.
Well, because of independence, it's just
the probability multiplied times each
other of the output of that,
of the particular symbol
seen at time t, given that you're
in the particular state at time t.
And that taken the whole product.
And that's just these b variables,
right?
So, b of q1 that of o1, means
the probability given that I'm in q1,
whatever q1 happens to be,
of outputting o1, and et cetera.
Okay?
So, if we knew the state sequence,
then we could just multiply this to
get the observation of the sequence,
of the likelihood of the observation
sequence given the state sequence.
But for any given state sequence,
I can tell you the probability
of getting that state sequence.
Right.
It's just a very simple product shown
here, right?
So, if I know it's q1 through q cap t,
then it's the probability,
here's pi of q1,
of starting in that state.
And then, a of q1q2, is the probability
of going from that state,
q1, to whatever the next state,
q2 is, times a q2q3,
all the way up to a qt minus one, to qt.
All right?
So, assuming I knew the sequence,
I could tell you the probability.
Well, you say, in that case,
I can do the following.
Given that I can compute
the probability of a sequence,
of an observation sequence,
given a state sequence.
And given that I can compute the
probability of any given state sequence.
Well, then, obviously, we can compute
the probability of getting that
output sequence by just summing over
the all the different state sequences.
Right?
Taking the probability of the state
sequence times the probability of the
observation given the state sequence,
summed, as I said,
over all the state sequences.
Okay?
You could just do that.
Of course the problem with doing that
is it would take you a long time.
How long?
A really, really, really long time.
And the reason is,
this is summed over all possible paths.
All possible state sequences.
All right?
Well, their end states and
their T times steps, that's N to the T.
Okay?
Exponential in time into the T.
And each one costs t calculations
because I have to figure out
the probability of oh, so the complexity
of that is T times N to the T.
That, as we say, is a really long time.
So, it's not such a good solution.
So, you think we can
do something better?
Well, of course, we could or
else I wouldn't be standing
here wasting your time.